well the bite administration while the
rest of us have been
otherwise occupied been awarding many
millions in chronovirus stimulus money
to people based on their skin color
alone this is illegal it's immoral and
it goes unchallenged stephen miller has
finally challenged it he's a former
white house advisor
his group america first legal just won
an injunction
against this racist policy stephen
miller joins us tonight
first of all thank you for doing this
second explain to the non-lawyers in the
audience what exactly this means
if you would absolutely well
you know i'm not a lawyer either i'm a
person who cares deeply about injustice
and about what's happening to our
country
just like millions of your listeners so
i put together a group
hired some of the best lawyers in the
country to stand up for civil rights in
america
we hear two terms a lot in this country
systemic racism
and institutional racism almost always
those terms
are wielded by progressives in a way
that is a lie
that is it that is dishonest that is a
smear
in this case we have real-life
institutional discrimination
real life systemic racism
where restaurant owners and farmers are
being denied
aid solely because of their skin color
that is not
only racist and bigoted it is flagrantly
unconstitutional and i'm proud of the
fact that we have won for our clients
in the restaurant case an injunction so
they're able to apply
and now we're seeking for all others in
their same situation
the same right under law to apply just
as
any other american we want equality not
equity which is code word for racism
why isn't the naacp joining you i
thought they were against discrimination
what we are finding out which is tragic
which is heartbreaking
is that progressives in this country are
willing to use the
awesome power of the federal government
to punish people
solely based on how they look or where
their ancestors come from
if we allow that to happen to our
children
to our colleagues to our neighbors to
our fellow citizens
the american experiment tucker it's over
those are the stakes here that's why i'm
doing this
that's why i am suing the body
administration to say
in this country you do not punish people
because they look a certain way because
their ancestors come from a certain
place
because if the government has the power
to destroy a business
because of how someone looks what's next
put someone in jail because of how they
look
take away somebody's entire life their
dreams everything they have
this is genuinely depraved it is sick
what is going on and it is
absolutely a violation of law
yeah and it's illegal in addition to
everything else that is everything you
said is true
unfortunately stephen miller thank you
so much thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else